Three dogs after that says,
how should a manager use the preto
principle in his favorite work?
I find myself constantly focusing on the
bottom five 20% that causes 80 95% of
the team's poor performance.
Oh,
that's easy.
The managerial literature,
the solid managerial literature is
absolutely crystal clear on this.
Spend all your time with your highest
producers and put your lowest producers
where they can do the
least amount of damage.
The probability that as a manager you're
going to be able to solve the problems
of the poorest five to 20%
of your work team is zero.
You just don't have the time or
the resources at your disposal.
So what you should jet definitely do
in order to increase performance is to
concentrate on your top performers.
I know that's not what managers do.
They do exactly what you say.
They focus on the bottom five to 20% but
that's exactly the wrong thing to do as
a manager.
Focus on your best people.
They're hyper productive
as you already know.
So,
um,
you know,
maybe you need to reconceptualize the
way that you're interacting with your
people,
but you should have regular conversations,
at least with those that
you think are outstanding.
Let them know that you really,
um,
what would you say that you're really
happy with their performance and see what
you can do to get obstacles
the hell out of their way.
Because as a manager,
essentially what you should be doing
is identifying the top performers and
they're doing everything you can to
clear out the obstacles in their path.
That's the right way to think about it.
And also to give yourself enough time
to develop a medium to longterm plan and
stop fighting fires on a day to day basis.
You need to at least 90 minutes a week
to think about where you want things to
be going into medium to long term.
So,
but I can't overemphasize the importance
of dealing with your top productivity.
You're top,
your highest,
your most productive people.
That's where all the gains are.
That's where all the games are.